happy Monday
I have two things before we get to our
guest uh this morning or this afternoon
today the president of first lady will
honor the 2023 teachers of the Year from
State and territories across the United
States for their excellence in teaching
and commitment to students learning this
year's National teacher of the year is
Mrs Rebecca Peterson a mathematics
teacher from Tulsa Oklahoma as a
classroom teacher for more than 30 years
the first lady is proud to continue this
tradition of celebrating teachers of the
year for their excellence in teaching
and commitment to students learning
from from day one the Biden Harris
Administration has been committed to
celebrating and elevating the teacher
the teaching profession and taking
comprehensive actions to increase
teacher pay improve working conditions
and develop high quality Pathways into
the teaching profession and given that
commitment it Bears noting that right
now speaker McCarthy is demanding we
slash education from
funding by 22 percent and if we don't
he's threatening he will throw the
United States into default and tank the
economy that's the equivalent of cutting
up to 60 000 teaching jobs affecting 25
million children and it would mean as
many as 7.5 million children with
disabilities could face reduced support
so today while celebrating our nation's
Educators the president is going to talk
about why slashing funding for education
is the last thing our country needs and
why this Administration is focused on
supporting our teachers and schools
also today the president shared that
domestic policy advisor Ambassador Susan
Rice will depart the White House late
next month Susan has served at the
highest levels of government for the
last three Democratic administrations
eight years in the Clinton
Administration eight years in the Obama
Administration and since day one here
with President Biden it's truly very
impressive she has served as National
Security advisor U.N Ambassador and for
the last two years brought steady and
capable leadership to the domestic
policy Council
thanks to her tireless efforts we
expanded and strengthened the Affordable
Care Act released a comprehensive
National mental health strategy and
finally enabled Medicare to negotiate
lower prescription drug prices for
seniors and cap the cost of insulin at
35 bucks
we've we've taken historic actions to
reduce gun violence and Advance police
reform we are making College more
affordable and accessible and fighting
for student debt relief
and we are increasing access to high
quality child care and long-term care as
the only person to serve as both
National Security advisor and domestic
policy advisor Susan's record of Public
Service makes history we are so grateful
to Susan for her service over the last
two plus years and to end to throughout
her career to our country on a personal
note I have known Susan for many many
years she is a she has become a friend
and a mentor to me and we are I am very
sad to see her go but also very thankful
for her service to this country with
that our national security advisor is
here today to uh to talk a little bit
about the upcoming State visit with
South Korea and also take any other
questions you may have on Sudan and
other foreign policy items go ahead
thank you Karine and good to be with you
guys today and let me start by echoing
what Karine just said I'm also very sad
to see Susan go uh although we still
have a few more weeks with her and and
um you know really grateful for having
had the opportunity to serve with her in
this Administration in this white house
as well as in the previous
administration as well
as Karine said I'm going to make a few
comments at the top and I hope you'll
bear with me because I want to be able
to talk through both the situation in
Sudan and the upcoming State visit by
the president of the Republic of Korea
and then a brief comment on what we saw
in fold up in New York today with
foreign minister lavrov's visit and then
I'll be happy to answer your questions
as you all know on Saturday on the
president's orders the United States
military conducted a successful
operation to extract all U.S government
Personnel from Khartoum we are proud of
the extraordinary commitment of our
Embassy staff who performed their duties
with courage and professionalism and we
are grateful for the unmatched skill of
our service members who successfully
brought them to safety we thank Djibouti
Ethiopia and Saudi Arabia Each of which
were critical to the success of our
operation
at the president's direction we are
actively facilitating the departure of
American citizens who want to leave
Sudan as the state department has been
urging them to do for years we have
deployed U.S intelligence surveillance
and reconnaissance assets to support
land evacuation routes which Americans
are using and we're moving Naval assets
within the region to provide support
American citizens have begun arriving in
Port Sudan and we are helping to
facilitate their onward travel
we're also supporting the efforts of our
partners and allies including local
Partners to evacuate or otherwise ensure
the safety of their people U.S Africa
command has established a deconfliction
cell for this purpose
we've made clear to the highest levels
of both the Sudanese armed forces and
the rapid support forces that they are
responsible for ensuring the protection
of civilians and non-combatants
including people from third countries
and humanitarian staff who are still to
this day working to save lives we
continue to condemn in the strongest
possible terms the violence between the
saf and the rsf and we have now deployed
a usaid Disaster Assistance Response
Team a dart team to the region to help
coordinate our humanitarian response
this tragic violence has already cost
the lives of hundreds of innocent
civilians it is unconscionable it must
stop the belligerent parties must
Implement an immediate and unconditional
ceasefire adhere to international law
allow unhindered humanitarian access and
respect the will of the people of Sudan
to return to a path of Civilian rule
I want to stress that we have only
temporarily suspended operations at the
U.S embassy in Sudan we fully intend to
resume those operations as soon as it is
safe to do so we remain deeply committed
to the Sudanese people and to their
future
also as you know President Biden will
welcome president Yoon to for the White
House's second official state visit this
week marking the first state visit by an
indo-pacific leader during the Biden
Harris Administration this visit also
marks 70 years of the US ROK Alliance
we're celebrating the last seven decades
of this Alliance and we're looking
forward to the next seven decades
under the Biden Harris Administration
the US ROK Alliance has grown far beyond
the Korean Peninsula and is now a Force
for good in the indo-pacific and around
the world
the two leaders themselves have
developed a rapport over the course of
the less than one year since president
Yoon took office in Korea
and they've had a total of four
engagements already just in that short
time
our economic and people-to-people ties
will be front and center on this visit
during the Biden Administration alone
just in the last two plus years the
Republic of Korea has invested over 100
billion dollars in the United States
that is translating to jobs across this
country this includes the Samsung
semiconductor Fab in Texas Hyundai's
work to build an EV Factory significant
new Investments by SK and Battery plants
among others
the summit will also celebrate what
we've been able to do under President
yoon's leadership since he took over
from unveiling at first ever
indo-pacific strategy to being the first
president of the ROK to ever attend a
NATO Summit to co-hosting the second
Summit for democracy the ROK is stepping
up around the world president Yoon has
also shown determination and courage in
his moves to improve ties between the
ROK and Japan an issue that has long
been of deep interest to President Biden
together president Yoon and prime
minister kashida are strengthening their
ROK Japan relationship in ways that
leave us all stronger and have helped
contribute to a stronger trilateral
relationship among the United States the
ROK and Japan
this visit of course also comes at a
critical moment as North Korea continues
to develop its nuclear and missile
capabilities the two leaders will have a
chance to consult closely on that
President Biden will reinforce and
enhance our extended deterrence
commitments to South Korea with respect
to the threat the dprk poses
the alliance remains committed to
pursuing dialogue with the dprk to
achieve a peaceful diplomatic resolution
to long-standing differences and to
achieve the complete denuclearization of
the Korean Peninsula we are ready to
meet at any time at any place to address
serious concerns and we are open to the
possibility of humanitarian assistance
with appropriate safeguards to help the
people of the dprk
while we've long been focused on the
Korean Peninsula though this Alliance is
doing far more than ever around the
region and around the world
the ROK for example has stood fast in
support of Ukraine since Russia's brutal
Invasion over a year ago the ROK is
committed to provide over 230 million
dollars in humanitarian assistance since
Russia's Invasion which includes
non-lethal military aid medical supplies
and generators and the ROK has also
joined the International Community by
implementing sanctions and Export
controls on Russia
on Wednesday President Biden and
president Yoon will announce major
deliverables on extended deterrence on
Cyber cooperation on climate mitigation
on foreign assistance on investment and
on strengthening our people-to-people
ties and we'll have more to share on the
specific deliverables tomorrow and going
into Wednesday
lastly I just want to take a moment to
recognize and lift up the words of
Elizabeth Whelan at the U.N security
Council today as you all know Elizabeth
is this is the sister of Paul Whelan who
has been wrongfully detained in Russia
for far too long now despite our quite
extraordinary efforts to bring him home
which the Russian government has
repeatedly spurned
I've met Elizabeth
and I felt firsthand what the U.N
security Council saw up close today she
is an incredible voice for all of us who
are outraged by the practice of wrongful
detention we'll keep working until we
brought Paul home and we will keep
working until we brought Evan home and
all Americans globally who are
wrongfully detained or being held
hostage thank you again for your
patience and hearing me out and I'd be
happy to take your questions yeah thank
you guys turning on uh facilitating the
department of Americans from Sudan what
is that American boots on the ground
what are what how many they estimated
Americans were there to intend to get
out or can you possibly get out of the
country well first we have not put
American boots on the ground in Sudan
other than for the brief period that we
brought the military in to evacuate our
Personnel we have placed ISR assets
intelligence surveillance and
reconnaissance assets over the land
evacuation route to help facilitate safe
travel by land from cartoon to the port
of Sudan and we have started to see a
more regular pattern of convoys begin to
arrive including convoys that have
Americans in them once at the Port then
we are using diplomatic facilities in
neighboring countries to help those
Americans with their onward travel so
that they can get safely out of the
country we anticipate that this route
will continue to be available for
Americans who are looking to leave and
convoys continue to get organized depart
cartoon and arrive at the Port of Sudan
as I mentioned we have also begun to
move Naval assets for any potential
contingencies
off the coast of the port of Sudan those
are the major ways in which right now we
are providing the kind of support and
facilitation to help Americans who want
to leave be able to leave and Americans
are in the process of availing availing
themselves of that and as I said before
we have seen Americans begin to show up
in the port of in the port of Sudan yeah
thanks Jake I'm just following up on
that maybe this is what some of the
naval assets are for in terms of
contingency planning are there U.S
emergency assets outside of or beyond
the intelligence capability and assets
that could be called on should one of
the convoids that has U.S citizens
inside of it come under attack so I
don't want to speculate about a
particular contingency but I will say
this uh the president immediately after
the outbreak of violence several days
ago I did order the deployment of
capabilities to the region to be able to
deal with any number of contingencies
some of those capabilities were used to
be able to get the Personnel from our
Embassy and and the military has walked
through the specifics of that
capabilities in countries near Sudan
remain available at the president's
disposal should they become necessary we
don't at the moment have any plans to
put those to use but we are prepared for
a range of contingencies and the naval
assets will add to that but that is not
the sum total of what we have available
in the region should it be necessary
yeah thank you doctor I know it was a
busy weekend for you
um you say the U.S has temporarily
pulled out of Sudan and will return when
it's safe to do so who is responsible
for the safety and the security in the
U.S embassy right now and curious if
you'd respond to the charges over the
weekend that in essence the Biden
Administration now has lost two U.S
embassies during the president's term
and I've got another lab if you don't
mind go ahead well so first what I would
say about the the question of security
at the embassy compound outside Khartoum
is that I don't want to get into
specifics on how it is that we are uh
taking steps to ensure its continued
security only to say that we had a
contingency plan in place we are now
executing that contingency plan uh that
can't guarantee obviously the security
of the embassy but we believe that we
have put steps in place to be able to
protect that compound uh in the days and
weeks ahead and that we do intend to
resume operations as soon as we are
capable of doing so I'm not sure what
you mean by a charge about quote unquote
losing embassies the uh the broader
diplomatic Community including the
entire United Nations community and
Khartoum has closed down in Sudan
diplomatic Personnel from allies and
partners around the world are being
evacuated and of course the United
States has evacuated its Personnel this
happens from time to time and if you
look back over the course of of months
and years you see military assisted
departures from embassies you see in
some cases non-combatant evacuation
operations that's in the nature of
having
270 total diplomatic posts around the
world there will be times when the
conditions are not conducive to
sustaining operations in all 270 at the
same time but our goal as I said before
is to be able to resume operations in
Khartoum as soon as we are capable of
doing so the Russian foreign minister
when he came to New York is
fairly upset that visas were not issued
to Russian journalists to accompany him
was that done in response to the
detention
I as you know when it comes to Visa
matters that is a matter for the state
department who is statutorily charged
with the responsibility of taking these
applications and responding to them so
it wouldn't be appropriate for me to
comment on that I'd refer you it over to
the state department yeah just as you're
talking about contingencies for sedan uh
will the U.S at any point be willing to
send peacekeeping troops to the country
I don't have any plans or announcements
to make about the United States point
peacekeepers to Sudan to putting
American boots on the ground to try to
keep the peace in Sudan that is not
presently in contemplation I don't
expect it will be sorry quick follow up
there can you lay out any of the
contingencies beyond the deployment of
Naval assets
anything you can talk about
what do you mean by sorry can you can
you talk about any of the contingencies
that you just were uh referring to so
look I'm not going to speculate about
things that have haven't happened all
I'm saying is that when it comes to
being able to respond in extremis uh
should we feel we need to do so to
protect the security of our people uh
who may be coming under threat the
United States uh has the kinds of assets
and capabilities necessary to be able to
do that but from our perspective right
now we believe that the current course
that we are on which is to continue to
try to facilitate and support this land
evacuation route is the best way for us
to proceed again that involves a set of
ISR assets it does not currently involve
U.S forces on the ground yeah mentioned
that you are seeing more Americans
arriving at the Port of Sudan but it
seems that last night and over the
weekend the state department was warning
Americans to be cautious of private
convoys because they were too dangerous
headed in that direction so did
something shift there because of the
assets that have been put in place and
is the message now it would be safe to
travel to the court so we are very
clear-eyed about this there are risks
with any potential option there were
risks when we flew helicopters in to get
our people out so we're not saying
anything is an iron-clad safe option and
it would be wrong of us to tell
Americans oh you got nothing at all to
be concerned about there's obviously
fighting happening in this country and
whether it's trying to leave by air or
by ground or shelter in place all of
them bring risks with them so we are
communicating risks quite clearly and
quite directly to people as we have
communicated risks over more than a
decade to tell Americans not to travel
to Sudan in the first place and to leave
Sudan if they were there but what we are
also saying is that for those America
who are interested in joining a convoy
we have been providing information about
how they can do that and then as I
mentioned before we are now providing
some degree of OverWatch to try and
ensure that these convoys can arrive
safely we have seen a number of them now
arrive safely we have seen Americans
among those Con boys and so we are going
to be very clear with Americans both
about the risks and about the available
options to them and we will continue to
stay in close communication with those
Americans who we have contact
information from uh and the state
department is doing that on a day-to-day
basis in some cases on an hour to hour
basis we remain available to any
American in Sudan who is looking for
support and guidance from the U.S
provide any update just on even the Hope
or possibility of a ceasefire where
negotiations stand I know the U.S is
still in touch with generals on both of
the warring sides is there any role the
White House and the president has played
in those talks anything
so we have had from the White House a
number of conversations with key people
in Sudan as well as from the state
department and from uh our ambassador on
the ground who was in daily contact
until he was pulled out but will remain
working the phones
um from his position now outside of the
country uh I don't want to speculate
about what will or won't happen because
it's a very Dynamic situation but we
have not given up on the notion that
there could be a ceasefire that comes
into effect and is durable there was a
ceasefire in place during a portion of
the Eid holiday there is as we speak now
efforts by both sides to have a
diminution in violence there is a goal
to continue extending that beyond the
end of the Eid period and we will keep
working with close Partners in pushing
the two sides to try to deepen and
extend the diminution and violence that
we have seen and to try to get a
permanent and durable ceasefire in place
I can't give you a prediction as to
whether that is likely to be successful
or unsuccessful we see the risk of
protracted conflict here but we also see
a possibility one that we are going to
exercise every tool we have available to
us that we could get to a ceasefire and
we want to drive to that if at all
possible yeah Jake what more can you
tell us about the Contours of the
nuclear deterrence package that you're
going to announce this week is it should
we view it in the context of the desire
on the part of the majority of people in
South Korea they should have their own
nuclear details
we will have the presidents the two
presidents actually uh release a
statement that deals with the question
of extended deterrence particularly in
the context of the threat and the
evolving threat posed by the dprk I'm
going to wait until we roll out that
statement I won't preview it in great
detail from this Podium but what I will
say is that we believe that that
statement will send a very clear and
demonstrable Signal of the United States
is credibility when it comes to its
extended deterrence commitments to the
Republic of Korea and to the people of
Korea and we also believe uh that the
ROK has been a good Steward of its
nonproliferation obligations under the
MPT and will continue to do so thanks
Jake one of the early kind of themes of
the messages of the administration was
foreign policy for the middle class I
was just wanted to ask is that still a
driving theme and is it now harder to
achieve considering these increasing
challenges around the world what's going
on now in Sudan pardon me as well as as
Ukraine
so you know I've heard some voices
saying for example we shouldn't support
Ukraine because we have to be focused at
home and my answer to that is the same
answer the Democratic and Republican
presidents have given over the course of
decades which is where the United States
of America we can and must do both we
can look after our people at home and
make far-reaching investments in the
middle class here for good paying jobs
for years and decades to come while also
standing up for the values that we hold
dear around the world including the
value of freedom and freedom for the
people of Ukraine we are capable of
doing both and that's not an abstract
proposition that is the last year since
the war broke out
in that time we have not only mobilized
an International Coalition to resist
Russian aggression and to protect
Ukraine as a sovereign and independent
country we have also made historic
investments in clean energy in
infrastructure in technology in the
United States investing in this country
in ways that are going to make the
middle class stronger more vibrant and
bigger than it was when President Biden
took office so from my perspective the
United States has significant
obligations around the world obligations
that relate directly to our national
security and to the well-being of
working people here in this country we
will discharge those obligations we will
do that while at the same time putting
in place the most significant set of
investments in more than a generation in
working people middle class people in
the United States and so I think the
results speak for themselves and the
answer is yes we still are committed to
a foreign policy for the middle class
yes thanks Jake you said from podium at
the U.S government has been telling
Americans not to go to Sudan for more
than a decade not and if they're there
to leave obviously that message has had
limited impact because there are
thousands
we're living in Sudan when the spiders
work out is there more that needs to be
done for Americans and countries where
you think they should not be to drive
home that message in a more direct way
so that there are harms way when danger
erupts so Americans are free people we
cannot dictate where they travel uh tell
them they must go or not go to a
particular place we can only give them
the best clearest most sustained most
consistent advice and we have been as
clear as consistent and as sustained as
we possibly can over the course not just
of this Administration but previous
administrations to tell people about the
dangers of living in Sudan I would also
point out that the American people do
need to understand as I've stood at this
Podium and said in other contexts like
in Ukraine it is not standard practice
for the United States to send in the U.S
military into war zones to extract All
American citizens we didn't do it in
Libya we didn't do it in Syria we didn't
do it in Yemen and no we didn't do it
Ukraine Afghanistan was a unique case
involving the end of a 20-year war that
the United States was centrally involved
in but Americans should understand that
we will do go to Great Lengths to
support and facilitate their departure
from difficult circumstances that we
will try to protect them from harm as
best as we possibly can but that there
should not be a broad expectation of a
massive military operation
to seize an airport or otherwise
evacuate people from a country
and and that has been the pattern over
the course of many years it is the
exception not the rule for us to do
something like that when it comes to
those Great Lengths you just mentioned
uh Kirby this morning said that right
now
know it's not very safe to try and run
some larger evacuation but should we
take that to mean that there is a
willingness to conduct a larger scale
evacuation if and when conditions
improve or no well there's certainly a
willingness to to take steps to help
Americans be able to get out of the
country and and if those steps in a risk
analysis included you know potentially
facilitating civilian flights or or
anything else along those lines the
president has asked for every
conceivable option to be able to help
Americans we would like to help as many
Americans go as possible but we want to
be able to do so in a way that is
fundamentally
reducing overall risk not increasing
overall risk that's the calculus that
we're making on a day-to-day basis and
right now we believe that the best way
for us to help facilitate people's
departure is in fact to support this
land evacuation route as well as work
with allies and partners who are uh who
are working on their own
evacuation plans as well
can you just take us a little bit behind
the scenes of the president's decision
to evacuate the embassy on Friday night
what you know what was it that tipped
the scale for him to realize yeah this
is go time
I think it was a combination of three
things one the opportunity presented
itself because it became clear to us
that this was a viable operation that we
could run it we could do it and so he
thought okay you've given me a
successful an option that will be
successful second
um it became clear also that there was a
decent likelihood that we would see some
form of protracted conflict even if
punctuated by moments of ceasefire and
so we couldn't just wait for the end of
this all and then third and finally
there were considerations which I won't
go into great detail here uh involving
how long you can sustain a platform with
the full complement of U.S Personnel
living at an embassy indefinitely while
fighting is Raging and supplies are
difficult to obtain so you put all of
those things together the president felt
this was the right moment it was the
right opportunity he directed his
military to seize that opportunity and
they successfully carried out the
mission yeah thank you Jake on Ukraine
wanted to give you the opportunities
response to a former White House
stenographer who this month outed you as
a Anonymous senior Administration
official who briefed reporters on Air
Force 2 in route to Ukraine in 2014. he
says that you spoke about giving Aid to
the Ukrainian national gas industry just
days after the first or the second son
had secretly joined the board of the
Ukrainian gas company he says he
considers you part of a corrupt
influence peddling conspiracy he wants
to testify to a Delaware grand jury
about it do you have a response to that
and were you part of a corrupt influence
peddling operation involving Biden
family and Ukraine or any other country
no
yeah thank you so much Jake two
questions uh one about the conversation
I had with your counterpart from Brazil
um about the comments abula comments on
the war in Ukraine do you believe that
conversation uh put the episode behind a
smoothie situation and today Brazil come
then
um the violation of Ukraine territory
integrity at the U.N security Council so
right now do you have confidence you can
count on Brazil on the matter then I
have another question about the
litigation going to Colombia I had a
good conversation with my Brazilian
counterpart Ambassador Marine we covered
a wide range of issues including Ukraine
and including some of the public
comments that we had seen it was
constructive it was detailed we agreed
we were going to follow up and have a
further longer strategic conversation
about the full range of issues that the
U.S and Brazil both face around the
world and I'll leave it at that for now
but I do have confidence in the
fundamental underlying strength of the
U.S Brazil relationship it is a relation
ship of two great democracies two
peoples who are Dynamic and Innovative
and there's a lot of good work we can do
together including for example in
protecting the Amazon and President
Biden just made a significant
announcement of U.S support uh for a
Brazilian initiative to be able to
protect the Amazon that's the kind of
thing that we should build on even as we
take on these difficult geopolitical
challenges together as well
we're both in the same line yeah go for
it and then okay thanks okay
um going to the state visit is the is
the question of South Korea contributing
to Ukrainian ammunition supplies going
to be part of the something they'll
discuss whether that's via the U.S or
directly to Ukraine thank you well I
will disappoint you by saying that I'm
not going to get into uh the private
conversations that they will have about
Ukraine obviously Ukraine is going to be
an important topic of conversation the
president will thank president Yoon for
the 230 million in non-lethal assistance
they have given
um the support on sanctions and Export
controls and then they will have a
chance to talk about the military
situation on the ground there but I'm
not going to go further or get ahead of
the president in terms of that
conversation that will take place when
President Yoon and he meet here at the
White House on Wednesday yeah I'll take
that and then I'll call it a day so
thank you Jack uh I appreciate the
cumberton today too on the 70s and
universities
[Music]
and the South Korean people are excited
about what kids president noon we bring
from this Sunday so what you know would
be the surprising agreement to the tune
present Union President Biden well if I
if I told you about the surprising
agreement then it wouldn't be a surprise
anymore so
um no I don't look actually I don't
we're not going to Spring something on
the world or on the American people or
on the Korean people I think the Korean
and the American people are expecting to
see a summit in which there are tangible
deliverables in the security space and
we will have deliverables related to
Extended deterrence in the economic
space and there will be announcements of
significant investments in the
people-to-people space and you will see
announcements in that regard as well and
then they expect the two presidents to
cover uh issues related to the big
topics of the day from the war in
Ukraine to The Climate crisis and so I
think uh this Summit is going to meet
the very high expectations that both
publics have from it and their right to
have a high expectations because we are
reaching a new level in strength the US
ROK Alliance I think that will be on
full display when President Yoon is here
on Wednesday and we are very much
looking forward to laying out the full
Suite of achievements and outcomes from
this Summit on Wednesday and I will not
further steal the Thunder from the
president either this president or the
ROK president before doing that on
Wednesday yeah mentioned the possibility
of
more than ten thousand North Korean
troops to do dembas how can you say
nobody's
Special Forces to dambas and Ukraine so
how are you going to tell you about this
I mean our position is that there should
not be Russian forces on Sovereign
Ukrainian territory and there shouldn't
be forces of any other hostile country
on Sovereign Ukrainian territory either
and and that position is clear and
unequivocal shared between the U.S the
ROK and every country that is voted to
condemn this brutal illegal war of
aggression being perpetrated by Russia
against Ukraine thank you guys
go undetected for so long
um I think the pool has to gather
oh oh it's open press okay all right
well
I guess you guys can go gather if you
choose to do
um
now sit down with the house Speaker
Kevin McCarthy now that he has released
his gallons of his plan on the debt
limit uh why is now the time for
president to actually speak to the
speaker and to get substantive
negotiations
um so here's the thing
um
Zeke remember
um look we've been very clear we're not
going to negotiate over uh or over
avoiding default we've been very clear
about that uh we uh the administration
is going to have a conversation with
leaders over the budget over the
spending cuts we've been very clear
about that uh and uh we've been we have
said that from the beginning from the
beginning of this process that look
we'll we'll have that conversation but
when it comes to default uh when it
comes to their constitutional Duty that
is something that they can do today they
can actually deal with something that
would be devastating if they didn't take
action right
um now when it comes to what we have
seen them put forward 22 percent cut on
education on Veterans on Meals on Wheels
on food safety on law enforcement all of
those things are devastating to workers
seniors to our children to Working
Families and clearly they showed us what
their value were but what they have done
is they have put those two things
together the the
debt ceiling and spending cut and we
have always been very clear Zeke we have
been very very clear we are not going to
negotiate when it comes to the full
faith and credit of this nation and they
are holding that hostage currently they
are holding the economy hostage and so
look they have to they have to we're not
negotiating over that and they have to
avoid default it's very clear it's very
clear they need to uh they need to make
sure that we're not put in a situation
uh where our economy could be put at
risk and again been very clear about
that I'm gonna I know we have to I think
we have to
yeah you have to leave now if you want
to cover uh if you want to cover and
I'll go for another I think once he
starts speaking we have to end so I'll
go for a couple more minutes go ahead
okay thank you uh just we saw the first
stone decision
um and so I wanted to we saw the
statement from the president of course
over the weekend as well
um just going forward as that case makes
its way through the courts what more can
we expect to see from the White House
and um from the president of course the
VP so look uh so the one thing that
really want to make sure that we are
that the American people understand it
nifa Preston is very much remains
available uh while we continue the fight
in courts and that's what we're
committed to do we've said this over and
over again this Administration the
buying Harris Administration is going to
continue to fight for women's rights
we're going to continue to fight for the
FDA to have the right uh to uh to make
these medical decisions to make these
evidence-based decisions and so that's
what we saw that's what the Judgment uh
really putting putting uh preventing the
lower cut decision from going into
effect which is incredibly important but
we are going to continue to fight and
we're going to continue to call on
Congress to codify row and that is
something that you heard that you saw in
the president's statement that you
something that you've heard from the
president uh many times again the Fight
Continues we're going to continue to
fight for millions of women who are
across the country and that will not
stop
a question on that a lot of retail
pharmacies the pharmacy chains around
the country are going through this
certification process to keep available
or even in some situations make them
available for the first time can you
give us an update on where can you stand
as the White House working with HHS
because that regulatory change was
proposed in January is there is there
any update on that because I don't have
an update that is something that HHS can
speak through much more directly what I
can say from here is that we believe
that we were prevailing the courts we
believe that the law is on our side and
we're going to continue to fight for
millions of women across the country
okay Joe uh yeah thanks Karine I want to
follow up on what Zeke asks there uh
Senator Klobuchar on CNN yesterday said
the President Biden should sit down and
negotiate with the speaker on the budget
but also make clear that the spending
cuts and you know should not be tied to
the debt ceiling and so when President
Biden sit down with McCarthy to debate
to negotiate their different budget
proposals or where what is the position
I want to be very clear here the House
Republicans position is unless the
president and the Senate agree to their
entire agenda that they're going to
default and crash the economy and and
that is dangerous that is something that
we're going to continue to call out and
it is unreasonable to do
we have been very clear there will not
be any negotiation around deep around
the debt ceiling right this is something
that is their constitutional duty to do
they've done it three times you've heard
me say it over and over again they did
it three times in the last
Administration and they should do it now
and look you know every every Republican
that votes for this bill that speaker
McCarthy and mega Republicans have put
forth they're voting for cutting cutting
costs on Veterans they're voting for
cutting costs on education I just laid
out at the top of the briefing what that
would mean sixty thousand have mentioned
sixty thousand teachers I mentioned how
many how many uh kids it would affect
and so that's what they would be voting
for against those things that American
families need and we're talking about
programs that they need to meet ends
meet and so we've been very very clear
it is unreasonable to put forth what
they did last week it is cool that piece
of legislation is cruel and so they need
to really make sure that they that we
don't go into default and that's what
they're asking to do they're asking to
hold our hold our economy hostage and go
into default and that's something that
we're going to continue to call out last
week you didn't seem to rule out the
possibility though of President Biden
sitting down with McCarthy at some point
is that something you're open
so look again House Republicans must
avoid default been very clear and that
is within their power to do at any
moment that is within their power to do
at any moment and so that's what we're
expecting them to see I think I have to
wrap it up super quick guys uh go ahead
uh in the so in the route you're all
shooting in Kansas City local leaders
are calling on the doj to step in and
pursue hate crime charges is that
something that the White House would
support I'm not going to get ahead of
doj that's something that they need to
decide we've been very clear about uh
Rafael as you know the president spoke
to him and his family last week to wish
him a speedy recovery and we've been
very clear on what how we see moving
forward when it comes to gun violence
and Congress to do more republicans in
Congress to do more
but that was the president was
politicizing the situation do you
believe that the president I didn't I'm
sorry I didn't hear the governor of
Missouri said the president was
politicizing the situation what the
president is doing is trying to protect
families and communities across the
country that's the action that this
president has taken the last two years
doing more almost two dozen actions in
executive orders to make sure that we
are stopping or trying taking steps to
stop an epidemic that we're seeing with
gun violence and that's what he should
do as presidents now we asked the house
of Republicans uh House Republicans to
do the same to have some courage so we
can protect our families and protect our
kids thanks everybody I'll see you
tomorrow